such special memories for me you know  it's wonderful to write a great great  scene great script or to give a fine  performance or to design a a magnificent  set but where would we all be without  the art of this cinematographer the  nominees for achievement in  cinematography are Chris Menzies for the  mission Jordan Cronin width for Peggy  Sue got married  Robert Richardson for platoon  Tony Pierce Roberts for a room with a  view  Don Peterman for Star Trek for the  voyage home  and the winner is the winner is Chris  Menzies for the mission  thank you very much for the honor and  for honoring the mission I'd like to  thank David Puttnam and Ferdinand gear  and Warner Brothers I'm very proud to  excuse me I'm very proud to work with a  very fine crew in the cast who gave so  much to the film but most of all thank  you to roland Joffe and his vision and  his inspiration thank you  you